this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists is minimalism good
for the soul
today we're going to talk about routines
and best practices to create
a fit soul now what does that even mean
maybe you're like me and you're
skeptical any time
anyone uses a word like soul
or spirit yeah it gets a little woo-woo
huh i i
feel like sometimes you don't have the
same allergic reaction that i do no i
don't i mean i was raised
uh to i was taught i should say that
the soul is flesh and blood
and the spirit is something different
and
in fact you know if you look at like the
greek or the latin
word for soul it does reference like the
actual body
and spirit is a little bit differently
so so yeah but regardless
there is i have this ability to hold
space
for even the woo-woo ideas
yes without actually believing them so
when i hear someone
like ben greenfield talk about the soul
and spirit
and and those things it may not be
exactly in alignment with my beliefs
right but i can hold space for the
context in which he is referring to
those things
i like what you're saying there because
what i've done recently is
held my beliefs a little bit more
loosely
as of late and it makes that same space
and so today we're actually
ryan and i aren't going to navigate your
soul don't worry right
but ben greenfield and rebecca sherin
are joining us today
to help us navigate these waters and
maybe put some
language around the soul and spirit
and and what it means to have a fit soul
that's we're going to talk about on the
minimal episode today
we actually recorded this while ryan was
out on vacation but then on the maximal
episode
ryan's going to come back with me and
we're going to talk about the minimalist
diet
which is uh well you have to tune in to
get the secret recipe
now we're actually going to be talking
about different types of of diets we're
talking about getting rid of dogma
letting go of dogma but also
understanding
what does it mean to be healthy and of
course ben and bex will join us for
that as well two extroverts because ryan
and i certainly aren't experts we've
talked to quite a few
experts about health about wellness
about food about exercise
and we're going to be tackling that on
the maximum episode today talking about
the minimalist diet over on patreon
speaking of patreon we just
launched new monthly simplified pricing
which has been overwhelmingly uh
lauded by our patrons it removed all the
confusion a lot of people were like
well i don't get it is am i paying every
week every time you release an episode
so now ryan and i can release
a thousand maximal episodes a month if
we want to
and you don't get charged any more money
so it's all benefit for you
you also uh have the ability now to do a
10 discount if you do
an annual uh if you sign up for an
annual membership
for patreon a lot of people have
switched over to the annual side of
things to
save 10 there of course that keeps our
podcast 100
advertisement free now you might notice
something different we're
if you're watching this on youtube we're
in a sort of transition
period the video you're about to watch
is in this temporary space that ryan and
i were in
because last year during covid our
studio the building our studio was then
closed down
we found a beautiful new studio space
yeah and thanks to our patrons we're
able to have it but
you see these backdrops behind us jordan
go ahead and look at ryan
you can see the backdrop behind him
we're working with a talented set
designer
named beulah and she's helped us with
these backdrops but
also she's helping us with what's behind
the backdrops
these backdrops aren't backdrops they're
wrapping paper i love it
it's a brand new gift that we're going
to give
to you so if you're watching this on
youtube by the way if you're watching on
youtube
make sure you go down there and you i'm
not going to tell you to click and
subscribe and all that other stuff
like subscribe share yeah don't do that
unless you're really compelled to i
don't care
but what i do care about is go click
on 1080p sometimes they automatically
degrade your
video quality and it drives me insane
that's so funny man because when i go to
see videos
like if it's a little grainy like it
doesn't it doesn't affect me at all
but i know that you have such an eye for
detail yes that you want to make sure
that our audience
gets the best viewer experience possible
right and we're going to be upgrading to
4k
eventually but in the meantime you at
least want it to be as high
hd as possible on youtube let us know in
the comments or don't
whether or not you are watching this in
1080p but you will notice
if you are watching this on youtube this
different backdrop and that's because we
have this beautiful new studio space
we're having sound panels installed new
for custom furniture
built so in the meantime we're using
these old sound panels it's actually
strangely
cluttered in here in fact we're getting
ready to do an episode ryan
about recluttering yeah because what
happens when you
declutter a space unfortunately one of
the easiest things to do is not pay
attention not be intentional what
happens
it gets re-cluttered re-cluttered
without even knowing it
and so by the way that's what happens to
all of us your house was empty before
you moved into it most likely
you're the one who cluttered it or
re-cluttered the space
and so we're gonna do an episode about
that we also have some episodes coming
up about computer clutter about
shopping addiction and also fake fame
new instagram fame and so if you have
questions about those
send your voice memos to podcast at
theminimalists.com
we'd love to answer your questions on
those upcoming
episodes and now this transition episode
you're going to see in a moment when ben
and bex come on the screen we're going
to be in a temporary space but then ryan
and i will be back in this space we're
gonna give you some listener comments
and insights we also have a beautiful
added value segment for you today and
some other stuff to talk about
as well but before we get into the this
episode the meat of this episode
here's a teaser for you the minimalists
are hiring three people for
this new studio space here in hollywood
if you're interested there's an office
internship
there's an audio video person graphic
design internship
deadline to apply is june 23rd
2021. you can find all the details at
the minimalists.com
interns if you are interested we'd love
to hear from you
enjoy this conversation with bex
and ben you're listening to the
minimalists i'm here with bex and ben
ben and bex we're talking about well
we're talking about a lot we're going to
talk about routines for a fit
soul ben i wanted to start with uh
talking about your new book fitsoul
which
i think people can actually download the
the electronic version for free is that
right
yeah i saw it on your website it's free
even even the print version
i i didn't want to make any money off
that and this isn't one of those
gimmicky go online give me your email
address you know
make money and just charge shipping and
handling for a book i literally
wrote that book decided i just wanted to
touch as many lives as possible
and um so you can download it for free
at fitswholebook.com
or you can get the physical version but
i it's just enough to cover my cost of
printing it and shipping it basically
well i'm just going to read the the
first paragraph on the back here
and then we're going to go over a few
pages from the book here do you
sometimes feel that no matter how much
wealth you accumulate toys you own
friendships you make
or physical and mental mountains you
conquer you're still at the
end of the day unfulfilled you sound
like a minimalist
speaking um well i want to go through a
few things here in the book so there
there is a page here on page 42 you talk
about the dangers of
transactional relationships
and um you know obviously love people
use things as sort of
that's our mantra with respect to
relationships too often we are
using people can you talk about the
dangers of transactional relationships
yes and to contextualize that every
chapter of that book
and really most the articles i i write
and release an article every sunday
morning
uh i i write to scratch my own itch
i've identified weaknesses in myself or
tendencies in myself
all things that i have addressed or talk
about in that book for example spiritual
unfulfillment or
ocd-like tendencies or disconnection
from family
or a feeling of disunion with god or how
i treat other people in the case of this
topic transactional relationships
and i find that in the same way that
when you're
angry with someone and you sit down to
perhaps write them an email
and you write them that email and then
all of a sudden you feel better and you
figured out the situation and you don't
send the email
that's kind of like my writing process
for the past year has been i have this
problem
i'm going to research the heck out of it
talk to a lot of smart people read some
books on it
do some podcasts on it and eventually
write an article about it
and as i'm going through and doing that
as we know one of the best ways to
learn is to learn in a fashion in which
you're thinking
how can i teach this to others and so
yeah i've written the entire book from
that standpoint because it's really been
a personal journey of enlightenment for
me using my writing
to kind of solve my own problems because
i figure if i struggle with this
then there's got to be at least a
handful of other people who do
and in my case what i found was that
from a transactional relationship
standpoint
i was treating my employees in
a very curt and and
short and impolite manner because
most of my interactions with them were
virtual
meaning that i was acting at the time
that i wrote that chapter as a virtual
ceo with my supplements company keon in
boulder but me living in spokane
washington and so i had a ton
of of chats via email or asana or slack
or whatever but it was
always very much just like you know do
this
do that yes no no
that doesn't look correct please fix
this this and this you know no
compliment sandwiches
no how's your day going no maybe pick up
the phone call and have a chat with
someone none of the same type of
experiences that you would have if you
were looking at someone in the eye
you know in the flesh and blood treating
them one-on-one because it is a lot more
difficult to have a flesh-and-butt
transactional relationship than it is to
have a digital
transactional relationship because it's
far easier to treat people as zeros and
ones and digits and avatars
simply because some of the realistic
personal experience is extracted
when we're talking to people in a
virtual scenario and
furthermore when we talk about
transactional relationships as you just
alluded to
joshua the the idea is that we also
can tend to see people as stepping
stones as something
that we can use to get to the next
level whether it be a promotion or
whether it be a raise or whether it be
relying upon that person as a customer
who's going to produce income for you
when if instead you are operating from a
position
of pure value of pure relationship
building of pure
really from a golden rule standpoint
loving others as much as you would want
to be loved
you become much more transformational in
your relationships and i believe it was
benjamin
hardy who first coined that term on a
medium article that he wrote about
transactional versus transformational
relationships and a transformational
relationship is one that
grows and thrives and abounds as you
become to know that other person
physically and mentally and spiritually
and you
uh you you're you're full of positive
energy in those type of relationships
you're not seeing that person as a giant
walking dollar sign or as a digital
series of zeros and ones that you email
with but as a real
flesh and blood member of the of the
human race
who you interact with on a on a daily
basis
and who deserves your love and your
respect and your forgiveness
and so yeah i think that because
it's so easy for us to create micro
businesses now and see people as
transactions
and as dollar signs and also interact
with them virtually
we all run a little bit of a risk a
little bit of a temptation to treat
people
transactionally when they should be
when they should be treated
transformationally and that's what i
explore in that chapter
the book seems to be centered around
these uh
ideas that um
well i i almost paired it with this
spiritual disciplines journal which we
can hold up here i don't think it's
available yet is it
i believe it is okay yes as of the past
couple of weeks okay okay well by the
time this comes out then it is available
um but when i look in here you you
center this
journal around four different uh pillars
can you talk about those pillars yeah
you know i'm certain that
you have addressed the topic of
gratitude on this show before and all
the the biological and social
and emotional and spiritual benefits
that arise
from a daily gratitude practice
including greater amount of empathy for
others
lower blood pressure lower plasma
cortisol levels
increase productivity often increase
success because
you are identifying or at least looking
for those things that you could be
grateful for thus introducing more
positivity in your life and also
accepting you know new opportunities
that arise that you've identified only
because you were looking like
there's all sorts of benefits of
gratefulness we could do a whole episode
on that alone
and being aware of many of those
benefits
i started a daily gratitude practice
years ago
right probably five or six years ago you
know every day
writing down one to three things that i
was grateful for
and um i i began to develop
that morning gratitude practice into
also journaling just a few other
questions
now that entire journaling practice has
blossomed not only into this
new book this new journal called the
spiritual disciplines journal
but also as a core part of my connection
with my family
every morning we do this journaling
practice together every evening we do
this journaling practice together
and it's been amazing for bookending our
day together
elaborate it's like you're spending an
hour in the morning it's pretty brief so
we we meet typically around 8 30 a.m in
our living room or in the summer
on the back porch underneath the
sunshine and we meditate together as a
family for 10 minutes
and then we pray together then we do our
journals and that's just how we start
each day
and then we end every day in the boy's
bedroom with a guitar
song with a story with a little bit more
prayer
and then with doing the other part of
our journal the evening part so the
morning part
is not only what am i grateful for
but also because i think that sometimes
when we set
positive intentions you know i'm good
i'm great i'm wonderful gosh darn people
like me i'm going to go make a million
bucks today and i'm going to own a red
carvet by next saturday
these positive intentions that are
helpful you know from a reprogram the
subconscious and a manifestation
standpoint
uh can often lead us however into
thinking of ourselves quite a bit during
the day so the second question that i
answer is
who can i pray for or help or serve on
this day
so you start the day with what am i
grateful for and who can i pray for or
help or serve
with a couple of subtle nuances there
the process of a gratitude practice is
the most powerful
when what you have written down that
you're grateful for is something
specifically that you received that you
feel as though you didn't actually
deserve
something you received that you feel as
though you didn't actually deserve
my grandfather called me last night and
talked to me on the phone for
20 minutes and expect that didn't
deserve that but it happened i'm super
grateful for that this morning
or um you know this morning i
i woke up and sometimes it can be
something as simple as
the sun is up and shining and beautiful
i didn't do anything to make that happen
i didn't deserve that but there it is
greeting me once again this morning
right it could be something that simple
for the praying or helping or serving
someone
it doesn't have to be especially if you
have a hyper busy day
you going over and like taking out your
neighbors trash and mowing their lawn
and you know and putting a bottle of
wine in their mailbox right
it can yeah it can be but can also be
you know and we know this is powerful
even from a from a quantum
physics and then the positivity of
photonic energy that we send out to the
universe standpoint
you can simply knowing that your friend
back in florida
is struggling with let's say you know
they're they're ill
you can simply say i'm going to pray for
that person whenever you know i wear
this bracelet this
five dollar bracelet from amazon so when
i write down homie i pray for help or
serve if it's someone specifically gonna
pray for
i look at my bracelet i'll say a quick
prayer for them but then whenever i look
at my bracelet again during the day
it reminds me to keep sending positive
energy and prayers towards that person
so it's almost as though you're starting
your day with a great deal of
empathy gratitude and serving others
and then at the end of the day you also
have two questions that you respond to
the first is based on this process uh
from the jesuit religion that would have
called
examine you know a guy like benjamin
franklin and many other great
philosophers and thinkers
used to self-assess self-examine at the
end of the day what good have i done
this day
and what could i have done better on
this day so that we not only
identify areas in which we really rose
the occasion and wish we were
we were more productive or we were more
impactful we were more meaningful for
other people or even something as simple
as
i planned my lunch ahead of time had it
all prepared
and that worked out really well because
i was able to be hyper productive and
have a wonderful nourishing meal during
lunch and not be rushing around
you know trying to figure out what was
going to stuff in my face at the last
minute
but these habits stack right like ooh
that was a good thing that i did this
day
let's let's make sure we repeat that and
that process of self-assessment also
lets you see how you're spending your
seconds your minutes
and your hours during the day because we
know how we live our days is how we live
our lives
and then the other question what could i
have done better this day allows us to
learn from our mistakes learn from our
failures it can become negative and i i
sense where you're going with this but
go ahead well i'm just thinking that
if we're always seeking betterment then
there is a
sort of lack of fulfillment with respect
because you're already born complete you
are
complete you you are complete and empty
room you don't need more stuff you don't
need more friends you don't need more
relationships
anything any of those things can augment
your experience of life
but if i feel as though i need those
things now all of a sudden it becomes a
chase
just like materialism is a chase
betterment can be its own sort of chase
how do you avoid that greed fully agreed
um the
the question what have i failed at today
or what could i have done better today
is not a question that is necessarily
designed
to um
to make you feel as though you didn't do
enough
or you need more it's designed to
identify certain patterns or habits or
rituals or routines during the day
that are not serving you or others best
and it can be something super simple
like i found myself
writing for nearly i think it was like
four or five days out of that week
didn't practice my guitar today and at
the end of that week i told my boys
because sometimes if i see something
repetitively being written
i tell them i'm never going to write
this down again i commit i am never
going to write this down
that i could have done better today
returning to my music because i know it
fuels me i know i love it i know it
relaxes me at the end of the day i know
it's good for my brain
and ever since that day even if it's for
two minutes at the very end of the day
after dinner when i'm
i pick up my guitar and i play and
sometimes it can also be
you know i open up facebook or instagram
or
twitter before i ate the frog this
morning before i did that thing that was
actually important
and i i could have done better on this
day the process of self-examination
allows you to identify those things
that that that really weren't serving
you or others best
and to commit to not repeating those
failures or to at least
learning from those failures in the
future and i find that it's that's been
powerful and in no way as
long as it's framed in the light of how
can i rise to the occasion something
that introduces like negativity into
your life at the end of the day
and then the the last question uh so
we've got gratitude service and
self-examination and the last question
is what is one way that i lived out my
life's purpose today
what is one way i lived out my life's
purpose today and you have a you have an
exercise in there that helps people
identify
because a lot of people are asking what
is the purpose of my life as though
there is a
assigned purpose and that's that's not
what you're talking about here
and i think it's good for some people
it's debilitating because they're like
well
i want to know what's the prescription
right uh
kapil gupta would say we are smitten by
prescriptions
and and it's not that you were born to
be an astronaut or an accountant
or a musician or or whatever it is is
that you can
find something that is purposeful to you
so how do you help people find what that
purpose is
yeah you are right i knew that if i just
asked people
what's one way you lived out your life's
purpose statement that that question
would be for naught if people don't
actually have a purpose statement and so
i have a series of exercises in the book
such as
answering questions like what did you
enjoy to do when you were a child
what makes time go by quickly for you
right now
um what is it that um
[Music]
that uh that that is a unique skill set
that you feel you were born with that
just comes
easy to you you know for example in my
case when i was a kid
i loved to write i would i write stories
right and a lot of
my wife's dyslexic and she would she
would paint right so now
you know my wife paints makes amazing
art and i
write but writing also like i can write
for what seems like two minutes and i'll
look at the clock and it's been a half
hour
makes time go by incredibly quickly for
me it's very self-actualizing i
i know that it's something i was born
able to do decently well
something i love to do when i was a kid
something that makes time go by quickly
now
so i know that probably part of my
purpose statement should include
writing you know meaningful content that
helps people and that's also important
that your purpose statement is
contextualized in a spirit
of loving others right so it should
never be in the same way that your
business statement in my opinion should
never be like we're going to make
you know a billion dollars by q4 of
2030.
it should be and said how many lives
you're going to touch how are you going
to
impact people and how many people are
you going to impact how many customers
are you serving
right and and the success and and the
the finances and the money will follow
that and so you you figure that out and
then
you say how you're going to love other
people with it so like my current
purpose statement
is to read write sing speak
compete and create in full presence and
selfless love to the glory of god
right or my son terence as he wants to
inspire people
to joy with creative art my wife's
is i want to minister to my family and
have our home be a pleasant and
hospitable place to be
right and so at the end of the day um
if you know if my wife spent the day
hunched over an article trying to
write something that she could put on
the internet about how to make her
roasted
chicken that would probably not be
something she would identify as a
purposeful activity
versus if we were hosting a dinner party
and she was downstairs because she loves
to do this right like making an amazing
meal and greeting people as they come in
and
you know and you know toasting with a
glass of wine all over her girlfriends
etc like
that is that that's purposeful for her
well this is so critical because
people often see oh this person's doing
that thing
and therefore i'm supposed to do that as
well prime example i have in my life is
uh
our filmmaker friend matt diabella who
who directed both of our netflix films
is one of the most talented he's he's
the most talented documentarian i've
ever seen
and i mean by far and yet after he
finished the first film he's like all
right i need to figure out what to do it
looks like
uh these guys josh and ryan they're uh
they published these blog posts
i guess that's what i should be doing
too and it's like no man you're you're
a master filmmaker but as soon as you
see someone doing something else you see
quote unquote success in that realm we
feel as though we're supposed to do that
but it wasn't his purpose as you would
right and when when you know that you're
going to be
writing down how you filled out your
purpose statement for that or how you
fulfilled your purpose statement that
day
you are programming your subconscious
right you know that throughout that
entire day
you're seeking out opportunities in the
same way that you're seeking out
opportunities to be grateful
you're seeking out opportunities to help
other people you're
committing to learning from the failures
of the previous day and also learning
from what you did good
that previous day you're seeking
opportunities to fulfill your purpose
statement and it's
you know seldomly but it happens there
are times when at the end of the day
i sit there and i have a really really
hard time thinking
of how i lived out my life's purpose to
me like geez i didn't
write i didn't like go play tennis or
compete i didn't create anything it was
just kind of like a
doo doo doo day yeah and um
and and so which is dangerous moment it
feels like you're doing something
purposeful it ape's
a form of purpose but it's actually the
opposite it's
it's work for the sake of work it's
keeping the hands moving without
actually doing something purposeful
right and so in in a sense it can also
be a way of
learning from your mistakes if that ever
comes up you're like geez i don't know
how i did live out my life purpose
statement today so
that's the that's the journal and what i
did was i
made a day for each of those questions
and you fill them out and you know
usually it takes about five minutes or
so in the morning and five minutes or so
in the evening
and i just put it all in the book and
and bound it up and just
just kind of launched it as the
spiritual disciplines journal bravo to
you yeah
is there a a link between sex and
spirituality
that's a hard pivot jesus well we're
talking about spirituality
yeah i do think that sex is a highly
sacred act that in many cases these days
is bastardized
as a an act of mutual masturbation
right many couples do not engage
in breath work or tantric practices
together
such as eye gazing or learning how to
move energy
up and down their spines as they are
making love
or um even doing things leading up to
lovemaking
such as um you know either doing
breath work together or meditating
together and i'm not saying that
sex i'm not saying that there's anything
against quickies right like sometimes
like me and my wife just want to slip
away and have some fun together
and you know scream and thrust and play
loud music and and just kind of like and
then
you know 15 minutes later we're done and
you know she's off to tennis and i'm
back down to the office to work on my
article or whatever
yeah but really from from a from a
real spiritual standpoint sex is an
extremely sacred activity the only
activity in which we engage that has the
potential to introduce
a human soul into the world one of the
few activities in which we engage
in which we are deeply physically in a
very intimate fashion connected to
another human being
we know from therapy such as you know
reeky or healing massage
or anything like that that there's a
great deal of photonic energy and life
energy
that is moving from one person to the
next when they are touching each other
and i think that sometimes in an era of
tinder and one night stands and quickies
and
all these you know things like you know
sex toys and porn things that can
sometimes
turn sex into almost a very carnal and
fleshly activity or be distracting from
you focusing on your actual partner
that sex can become i guess kind of in
the same way that we talked about how
relationships can become transactional
sex can become transactional to a
certain extent when
sex especially if it's sacred sex done
in a deep spiritual and meaningful and
planned way with your partner
can be something transformational and
again i'm not saying everything has to
be an
epic sex romp you know hotel or
staycation
with you know yoga and breath work and
plant medicines
and you know oxytocin nasal spray and
whatever else beforehand
and you know and eye gazing and tantra
and breath work but i am
saying that you should be highly highly
cognizant during the act of love making
that is a deeply spiritual activity
probably one of the most spiritual
activities that two human beings can
engage in together so it's sacred
when did you start talking to your kids
about sex
probably three years ago
um i started taking them through a few
of the david dita books
um you know he has some great books
including finding god and sex
and also um the way of the superior man
which has a great deal of discussion
about sex and relationships
uh although i'm i am a christian and he
has a slightly different perspective
on like that kind of like a christian
view of sex
uh because i you know i'm monogamous and
and believe in
the the the the the
holiness and reverence of marriage and
how special relationship that is
you know i certainly just tell my boys
certain things as we move through that
based on what i believe
i've taken them through all the breath
work practices in the multi-orgasmic
male
we've gone through the entire anatomy
and physiology book on the reproductive
system
and this has all been over about the
past three years or so and then we have
a very open household in terms of they
know any question they have for mom or
for dad about sex about their bodies
about anything like
you know i i grew up in a home where
much of that was like forbidden fruit
you just didn't talk about it right so i
turned to things like you know porn and
videos and
uh you know my friends to learn about
sex
whereas i think in an ideal scenario a
child should be learning about that
from their parent with in a responsible
open and transparent fashion at home
yeah so you started sort of talking with
specifics around the age of 10.
with your boys 9-10 yeah yeah ella's
starting we have a
almost eight-year-old daughter and she's
starting to ask like
peripheral questions more like how are
humans made you know like not so much
nuts and bolts but like
sure process of where do humans come
from
right yeah so yeah i think that um
depending on your relationship
with your child it can be beneficial to
actually
not necessarily wait until they ask the
questions yeah
but but i mean honestly just say okay
well you know this is the time when
i want to spend a week you know this
this is why i map everything out so i'm
like okay
march 11th through 19th we're getting
the anatomy book and every night we're
gonna you know because
you can't fabricate new hours but like
we're skipping story time and instead
i'm taking them through the reproductive
system
in the anatomy book for seven nights in
a row you know during this
time block or we're going to go visit
the website your brain on porn and we're
going to spend an hour on that together
watching videos and learning about how
it affects your neurotransmitters and
what porn is and
how to contextualize that properly you
know in terms of your relationship to
the opposite sex and objectification you
know everything else that might be
wrapped up around that industry
um and perhaps another time we're going
to do breath work in the sauna with the
pelvic locks and with moving energy up
and down the spine but during that
process i'm going to explain to them
that
during the act of love making that's
also a tactic you can use it's not just
for breath work
and so you know i just kind of weave
things in when you unschool your kids
right
so is it kind of like it becomes
from my impression anyways is when
you're when you're unschooling
it there's just sort of a continual
learning process that's
very flowy throughout the day and
throughout the weeks and the year like
yeah it's kind of weird because you
often have these moments you're like oh
crap nobody's teaching my kid that like
sometimes you'll think of something
because it's so easy when they're going
to school and you're like yeah that's
taken care of they're going to get
taught that covered
and then you know so for me you know
every month when i'm reviewing their
schedule you know what core blocks of
curriculum or what studies or what field
trips what activities or tutors or
sports or anything else they're
engaged in you know i i actually have to
pay a lot closer attention because
like whatever i put on their plates or
they choose and cooperate with me to put
on their plates like
that's what they're learning and and
sometimes i get nervous i'm like
doing enough math or like should they be
reading at a different level and
you second-guess yourself a lot but it's
a ton of fun like i i honestly like love
to see them just learning in an
experiential based way just from
life's lessons yeah well i feel like you
know we do a lot of raising of ella
and i realize this is off topic but like
in a very like open and honest way and
whenever she has questions about stuff
we
we do our best to be super honest and
super straightforward
age-appropriate but like we'll answer
any question she asks
and so i feel like there's a certain
instead of relying on teachers to
to provide the education like she looks
to us
for for a lot of her knowledge and her
understanding
one thing that that comes to mind
because i just started doing this and
it's super powerful
and uh i i wish i'd started doing it
earlier
is about once a week with your kids like
for
for about four years we've been doing
eye gazing
where you know around once a week or so
we'll just put on a song play a nice you
know song
that's you know usually like a yoga or
meditation track or anya or whatever
something that's kind of cool in the
background and you just look at each
other for like four or five minutes just
deeply into your child's eyes and you
can also do this with your lover
but you're just looking at each other
you know completely in the eyes of the
window to the soul
and sometimes you'll say sweet nothings
like you know i love you or
you're getting so big or you know or
they'll say something like i'm so
grateful for your dad but it's not
talking as much as just looking
and um and then we started throwing this
question in so you look at them and
you're looking straight into your eyes
and you're like
how's your life right now on a scale of
one to ten
and what would take it to a ten and it's
really interesting just to see what
comes up when you're in that special
place looking into each other's eyes and
um
and and you just you learn interesting
things each week from your kids
you ask them that question you know and
you'd think a kid would would start to
learn to be
manipulative and say something like well
ice cream yeah tonight every night
yeah but definitely you know like like
the last time we did it
um it was so cute like my son taron he
said
i wish i had more time to pray and
meditate in the morning
i'm like wow i would not have said that
when i was like 13 years old
and um then then my other son
said that he wanted to play more family
games
at dinner that were like more widely
varied we kind of got in the game rut
and it's like oh okay well that's that's
good to know but sometimes that
eye-gazing practice of just stopping
looking asking your kid
the one to ten question it can be kind
of meaningful it sounds like you can get
some surprising answers i know this week
bex asked ella what her favorite part of
school was and she said mindfulness
which
is shocking to both of us um but
like had you not asked we wouldn't know
right
and then it's like okay well how do we
now incorporate mindfulness
and more because it doesn't feel like as
though it's
a forced thing you certainly don't want
mindfulness to feel like a punishment to
an eight-year-old girl
right uh because that's accomplished the
opposite of what you're trying to do
yeah that's difficult too like like
choosing let's say you do need to
discipline and there's some punishment
that needs to be doled out
yeah like i like i see a lot of parents
having it be especially like parents in
fitness which is their ramen whereas
like
you got 100 extra push-ups today because
you didn't take out the
garbage yesterday and that's like your
chore or
um you know or drop and do 30 burpees i
never use exercise as a form of
punishment because i
never want them to associate exercise
with negativity yeah
like if they didn't take out the garbage
the previous day because that was part
of their chore
maybe they're scooping dog poop in the
backyard exactly right as part of their
extra chore for for the next day
or something like that so there's some
amount of of discipline that occurs by
never discipline with anything that
would be considered
positive right in the same way that you
wouldn't want mindfulness to be
something that you
that you you know turn into a chore
exactly we also try to not use
i know a lot of people use food as a
reward
right and we try to really avoid that at
all costs
right and it happens to be particularly
powerful with
with our daughter like she has a huge
sweet tooth and so it's really
a strong driver for her but like i i try
to stay
far far away from that because it can go
down the road of
of disordered relationships with food or
disordered relationships with activity
and it just
food is something people gather around
they celebrate around they build
relationships around you know that whole
idea of breaking bread together
and toasting and singing and so food in
our house
is something that you know aside from
you know whatever dad's quick smoothie
i'm going through a few emails in the
morning but but
actual you know celebration of food is a
really fun affair
and so i'm actually okay with food being
a reward if it's not the food that's the
reward but it's like
you know oh man you just you crush you
know every single book report that dad
had you do
like this entire month like i had
nothing to correct it was amazing
we're gonna go out to a restaurant and
you know like we're we're taking mom and
your brother
and we're gonna you know we're gonna go
to a restaurant and
walk and go see the ducks by the pond
then go then go up and have an amazing
meal and you get your own mocktail
and yeah you know and turning to
experience so i think it depends on how
food is is given his love and if it's
part of like a greater experience it's
okay but if it's like
you did it you get to go pick out the
snickers bar that you never get to eat
from the gas station and have the
biggest snickers bar because you
and it's like that i think that creates
a different scenario that's an important
distinction
yeah right because it also puts that on
a pedestal as though it's something
that one should strive to attain oh if i
do even better maybe i'll get the
king-size snickers bar
right next time right it can create
especially for people who
who grow up i've noticed like a a train
to eat eat to train
type of like you see this a lot in
exercises it's like i'm gonna crush
myself in the gym this morning
so i can go have that 1 000 calorie acai
peanut butter bowl
because i love it but i got to go punish
myself first because i was going to hate
myself afterwards if i just wake up and
go eat that
and then you know they finish that and
they're like i gotta like i gotta go
for a 90 minute hike on the treadmill
before dinner now because i had that big
bowl
and then dinner rolls around they're
like a 90 minute hike on the treadmill
after dinner i know that ice cream is
there in the freezer
and you see people starting to reward
themselves for physical activity
and then once they reward themselves
realize they need more physical activity
to burn off that reward
and it's this vicious cycle a vicious
cycle do you think that that is
that vicious cycle that one in
particular or cycles like it
that sort of negativity cycle where one
behavior
that you know is hypothetically good
maybe it's overwork
right um do you think that's driven by
you know a lack of a certain fulfillment
or
or feeling whole or
yeah um uh
st augustine called it the god-shaped
abyss you know another author named
bliss pence's a a religious author
referred to it
as as a god-shaped hole in one's heart
um it's this idea and there's even a
book about this called eternity in their
hearts
like every human being has a sense deep
down inside that there's something
bigger out there as you might hear in a
disney princess song you know something
more to life than this
anybody who's had a it's kind of funny
because you know most
like atheists who go into a plant
medicine for experience for example
don't walk out as atheists like all of a
sudden they're like aware that there's
something greater out there
because they've experienced god or light
or love or christ or something of that
nature
and it is this idea that because we have
that longing in our souls for something
greater
sometimes we're like oh that's something
greater is me doing an iron man or
climbing the seven peaks or losing x
percentage of body
fat or becoming a millionaire or a
billionaire
or learning how to memorize a deck of
cards
or you know becoming a virtuoso on the
violin
or eating a whole bunch of food or just
exercising myself into a pit
because something has got to scratch
that itch right
and i think that until you feel the
god-shaped hole in your heart with what
actually fills a god-shaped hole which
is
god then you're always searching to a
certain extent
and so i think that one of the best ways
to fill that god-shaped hole in your
heart
is by beginning to care for your soul
which is what i talk about you know for
example in fit soul
the spiritual disciplines like
meditation and gratitude and
journaling and silence and solitude and
prayer and charity and service and
relationships and love
and all these things that we can tend to
neglect when life gets busy because
some of the carnal things we do like
working out or
going to walk in the sunshine or
something like that like they feet we
can feel them right away
whereas sometimes you can't necessarily
feel every aspect of soul care right
away
but that's the one part of you that's
going to go on to exist for all eternity
therefore that is arguably the one part
of you that you should be caring about
the most so that you can experience that
fulfillment and that that's what fit
soul is about that's why i did the
spiritual disciplines journal also to
help equip people with what they needed
to develop a fit soul and yeah i think
until
someone actually finds that fulfillment
whether it is food or anything else
they're always going to be trying to
fill that hole with something
yeah ryan you got to fill that hole with
something got to fill it with something
man
we are so mature i'm turning
40 this month oh my god it's my birthday
month we're going to do a birthday
i'm boycotting 40. you should boycott 40
with me i'm either 39 or 41. i will
never be 40.
your age is going to be redacted exactly
on all of our documents
yes well thank you to ben greenfield and
rebecca sherin for joining us today
check out ben's podcast it is called
the ben greenfield fitness podcast you
can also check out bexa's podcast it is
called
how to love i co-host that with her you
can find that on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you listen to podcasts or
at howtolove.show now ryan
before we get into our added value
segment this week do you have anything
special for us
um no am i supposed to have something
special for you how about these listener
comments and insights
check them out hi josh and ryan it's
connor from toronto
i'm 17 and i'm out finishing grade 11
right now so
exams are coming up and my mental putter
is coming to an all-time high right now
so
i use something to help me focus on
setting and writing that i recently
started using
and it's an app called pomodoro timer so
that's p-o-m-o-d-o-r-o
it's a really simple timer app and it's
based on a kitchen timer that uses
a productivity practice called the
pomodoro technique
it's a time management method that's
used to break down
work into intervals traditionally 25
minutes of concentrated work
separated by short five minute breaks so
after a number of cycles
reward yourself with a long break that's
usually 15 minutes
and on the app you can adjust the
duration of the work sessions and breaks
you can set daily targets and you can
even catalog your progress
over time so i found it that over time
i've been working more productively and
getting more out of my study sessions
and i hope you could find value in that
too thanks
hi my name is natalie i'm from cochrane
ontario
so i want to start by saying that i
really enjoyed your recent
stop buying podcast i would like to
share
how i limit my shopping on amazon
i only pay with gift cards when shopping
online
so once i have added the items to my
cart i then have
to buy a gift card at the store and
apply it
to my account before finalizing my
purchases
this makes buying online less convenient
and it allows me to think before i buy
if it is not worth my time going to a
store and buying a gift card
then i probably don't need the items in
my cart
just a reminder we're going to be
talking about the minimalist diet we're
gonna talk about letting go of ideology
and
much more about minimalist wellness
that's this week on patreon that's the
maximal episode this
thursday patreon.com the minimalist now
ryan for added value this week what do
you got
there's a songwriter his name's uh
you've heard of bj thomas i assume
maybe i'm not as cool as you man okay
sean you say 50s 60s
60s mostly yeah oh get out of
keep falling on my here oh raindrops
keep falling nice
okay so he someone sent me this
apparently he passed away recently oh
and
and so but he had the song i mean
so the name of our book is love people
use things
it comes from the the epigraph here at
the beginning there are two people
there is the archbishop fulton j sheen
in 1935 who said
you must remember to love people and use
things rather than to
love things and use people and then
almost a century later
the pop philosopher drake drizzy
he said wish you what he sang wish you
would learn to love people and use
things and not the other way around
i really want to sing it like
would you love hayes like
drake's in the room with me a very ill
drink
anyway um well there's a song from bj
thomas called using things and loving
people
oh and so you're going to hear that
today i thought it was the appropriate
way to
to sum up this whole episode because
regardless of what your beliefs are and
how closely you hold them
we all understand that life is better
if we're not loving things yeah and
using people
so enjoy this song from bj thomas by the
way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
how do you plan your meals as a
minimalist particularly when it comes to
dining out
what is the most minimalist diet vegan
paleo keto breatharian
are there people really who are
breathtarians you know what just tell me
in the maximum
for a short period of time i assume
i mean i am currently like i know i'm
not putting food in my body at the
moment
so i am right now but we'll we're going
to investigate that a bit more okay
what are 10 foods that you would
eliminate from the standard american
diet we're going to talk to ben
and bex about that you know bex is a
registered dietitian she's a
nutritionist
ben is one of the smartest people i know
when it comes to health and wellness and
diet and exercise plus we got a million
more questions for ryan and me
and ben and bex and if you want to hear
all that join us on the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
theminimalists.com support to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
private podcast plays in your favorite
podcast
app you know this is the time because we
have the new monthly billing you're
supporting
our studio it's keeping us a hundred
percent
advertisement free it allows us to pay
jordan and sean
and jess and so thank you for supporting
the show
if you are supporting the show but
you're not just donating you
are getting so much more the maximal
episode every week is much longer than
this minimal
plus you get all the other things that
we share just on
patreon yeah the minimalists.com support
if you'd like to subscribe
you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email us
a voice memo podcast at
theminimalists.com
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
any new writings that we publish for
free and if you leave here today with
just one message
let it be this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it bye